good morning
um and uh welcome to this event on EU
China relations with the president of
the European
commissioner line welcome I'm very glad
to have you here
I'm Fabian zulik the chief executive of
bepc and it's my pleasure to co-host
this event together with Merricks and
Mikko hortari we at the EPC believe that
cooperation between think tanks is very
important and that together we can
increase the impact of what we think
things do so it's my pleasure to be able
to work together for this seminal speech
on EU China relations
we truly live in a new era after the
Watershed movement of Russia's Invasion
after all the global changes we have
seen
and in the latest iteration of this
Perma crisis as we at EPC have called it
clearly the role of China is very
important it's very important to see how
the global era is developing the
geopolitical commission is going to deal
with an important country like China so
we are looking very much forward to the
speech
and the discussion which then will
follow and I'll hand over to Mikko to
say a couple of words as well
the president ladies and gentlemen
Fabian a warm welcome also on behalf of
the McCarter Institute for China studies
Merricks my name is Miko tari I'm an
executive director of this institute
we're very grateful for the opportunity
um to host this increa extremely
important event and partner with EPC I
think it's a good expression of our
cooperation in the past years our
mission at Merricks is getting China
right providing the best possible China
analysis on developments in China
outside China and on this most
consequential relationship for the EU
we're grateful for the support of the
commission that has invested in
independent knowledge on China over the
past years and we're very grateful for
the support of our foundation and the
partners and the members of our
Institute and with that I think I would
like to hand over to the president for
her speech and we look very much look
forward to your introduction and then
later to the discussion thank you so
thank you so much thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
it's a real pleasure
to be here at this very special event
co-hosted by two of Europe's Most
knowledgeable
and in independent-minded think tanks
in a time when Global Affairs are
becoming harder to decrypt
and in an era where facts are routinely
challenged
the work that you do at these think
tanks has never been more important for
Europe
because it is only by having a deeper
understanding
of the world as it really is
not as we may wish it to be
that we can develop better informed
policies
and this is why I believe think tanks
are an essential part of our democracy
just 10 years
Merricks has developed a unique
expertise
in analyzing the political economic and
social trends in China
and how these impact Europe and the
world
and we must preserve and uphold your
right
and that of all think tanks
to be analytical
and to be critical
so I want to express my solidarity with
you
and all the other individuals and
institutions
who have been unfairly sanctioned by the
Chinese government
I would also like to congratulate the
European policy Center on its recent
25th anniversary
from the outset you have been a truly
European voice in the world of policy
and Academia
this spirit is very much in the image of
one of your founders
and one of Europe's Most unheralded
fathers
Max kunchdam
Max krunchstam lived through personal
trauma and tragedy during World War II
and this experience
inspired him to dedicate his life to
building a United Europe
one question
always guided his work
and I quote
do we believe that states are forever
condemned to remain
never to trust another state
or do we believe in the possibility
of change
of gradually changing men's Minds
and their behavior
end of quote
commitment to creating a better
understanding between people
lives on through Europe's Think Tank
Community
and it is this need
to deepen our knowledge of a rapidly
changing world
that brings us here to discuss Europe's
policy towards China
our relationship with China is one of
the most intricate
and important anywhere in the world
and how we manage it
will be a determining Factor
a factor of our future economic
prosperity and National Security
China is a nation with a unique history
dating back from early civilization
through the rise and fall of dynasties
yeah
its philosophers have shaped culture and
society and much of today's world
from Laos teaching
about living in harmony with nature
so the ethical values of Confucius
four great inventions of ancient China
the compass
gunpowder
paper making
and printing
revolutionized World Civilization
at this later latest era is in many ways
one of the most remarkable chapters
in that long winding and often turbulent
history
in less than 50 years China has moved
from widespread poverty and economic
isolation
to be the world's second largest economy
and the leader in many cutting-edge
Technologies
since 1978 growth has averaged over nine
percent per year
and more than 800 million people
were lifted out of poverty
is one of the greatest accomplishments
of the past half century
China's reach stretches across all
continents and Global institutions
and its Ambitions are far greater still
the belt and Road initiatives it is the
largest lender
to developing countries
and its economic industrial and military
power
what's into question any notion
of China itself being still a developing
country
we heard that last October when
President XI told the Communist Party
Congress
that by 2049
he wanted China
to become a world leader
in and I quote
composite National strength and
international influence end of quote
or to put it in simpler terms he
essentially wants China to become the
world's most powerful Nation
given its size and Global influence it
is positive
that China's economy has eventually
reopened after covet
and it is good that our citizens
businesses and diplomats are able to
exchange once again
because understanding each other
starts with speaking with one another
what
at the same time
we are concerned
by what is behind this return to Global
stage
defining a European strategy towards
China
defining what success looks like
must start with a sober assessment of
our current relations
and of China's strategic intentions
our relationship with China is far too
important to be put at risk
by failing to clearly set the terms of a
healthy engagement
it is clear that our relations have
become more distant
and more difficult in the last few years
we've seen a very deliberate hardening
of China's overall strategic posture for
some time
and it has now been matched by
ratcheting up
of increasingly assertive actions
there was a stark reminder of that last
week of that last week in Moscow during
President xi's State visit
APR from being put off by the atrocious
and illegal invasion of Ukraine
president XI is maintaining his No
Limits friendship
with Putin
but there has been a change of dynamic
in the relationship between China and
Russia
it is clear from this visit
that China sees Putin's weakness
as a way to increase its leverage over
Russia
and it is clear
that the Power Balance in that
relationship
which for most of the last century
favored Russia
has now reversed
most telling were president xi's parting
words to Putin on the steps outside the
Kremlin when he said and I quote
right now there are changes the likes of
which we haven't seen for 100 years
and we are the ones driving these
changes together
end of quote
as a permanent member of the security
Council China has a responsibility
to safeguard the principles and values
that lie at the heart of the UN Charter
and China has a responsibility
to play a constructive role
in advancing advancing a just peace
that peace can only be just
if it is based on upholding the
sovereignty and the territorial
Integrity of Ukraine
Ukraine will Define the terms of a just
peace
that requires the withdrawal of invading
troops
any peace plan
which would in effect consolidate
Russian annexations
is simply not a viable plan
we have to be frank on this point
how China continues to interact with
Putin's War
will be a determining factor for
eu-china relations going forward
and of course China itself has also
taken a more assertive stance in its own
neighborhood
the show of military force in the South
China Sea and East China Sea
and at the border with India
directly affect our partners and their
legitimate interests
we also underscore the importance of
peace and stability in the Taiwan Strait
any weakening
of regional stability
in Asia
the fastest growing region in the world
affects Global Security
the free flow of trade
and our own interests in the region
the grave human rights violations
occurring in xinyang
are also a course of great concern
as laid out in the recent report of the
U.N High Commissioner for human rights
how China meets International obligation
regarding human rights
will be another test for how
and how much we can cooperate with China
just as China has been ramping up its
military posture
it has also ramped up its policies of
disinformation and economic and trade
coercion
this is a deliberate policy
targeting other countries
to ensure they comply
and conform
we saw it when China responded to the
opening of a Taiwan office in Vilnius
by taking retaliatory measures against
Lithuania and other European companies
we have seen it with popular boycotts
against clothing brands
for speaking out on human rights
or with sanctions against members of the
European Parliament
officials
and academic institutions
for their take on China's actions
we've seen that member states
increasingly
have to deal with Chinese activities in
their societies
which are not tolerable
and we have seen it in the region
for example when China severely
restricted Australian exports of Bali
and wine
because of its government's questions
on the origin of covet
this is all part of a deliberate use of
dependencies
and economic Leverage
to ensure that China gets what it wants
from smaller countries
ladies and gentlemen these escalatory
actions point to a China that is
becoming more repressive
at home
and more assertive
abroad
there are three broad conclusions we can
draw on how China is changing which in
turn must shape how our policies will
need to change too
the first
is that China has now turned the page on
the area of Reform and opening
and is moving into a new era of security
and control
we saw this earlier this month when
President XI repeated his pledge to make
China to make the Chinese military and I
quote
a great wall of Steel that effectively
safeguards National sovereignty security
and development interests end of quote
we saw it with beijing's Global Security
initiative
which it seeks to embed in U.N documents
and international discourse more widely
we can expect to see a greater focus on
security whether military Tech or
economic
all companies in China for example
already obliged by law
to assist State intelligence gathering
operations and to keep it secret
we can also expect even stricter
economic control measures as part of a
strengthening of the Chinese Communist
Party steering of the economy
through its institutions and leaders
and we can expect to see a clear path
and push
to make China less dependent on the
world
and the world more dependent on China
put it bluntly a few years ago and I
quote
China must tighten
International production chains
dependence on China
to form a powerful countermeasure and
deterrent capability end of quote
this is especially true when it comes to
critical raw materials like lithium or
Cobalt for sectors like High-Speed Rail
and renewable energy technology
or for emerging Tech that is Central to
Future economic and National Security
like Quantum Computing or Robotics and
artificial intelligence
the second conclusion we can draw flows
from this
and that is that the imperative
for security and control
now trumps the logic of free markets and
open trade
in his report to the recent party
Congress
president XI told the Chinese people to
prepare false struggle
and it is no coincidence
that he used in his opening speech
the words doesn't
and fendo
repeatedly which both can be translated
as struggle
this is indicative of a world view
shaped by a sense of mission for the
Chinese Nation
which brings me to the third conclusion
and that is that the Chinese Communist
parties
clear goal is a systemic change
of the international order with China at
its Center
we have seen it with China's positions
in multilateral bodies
which show its determination
to promote an alternative vision of the
world order
one where individual rights are
subordinated
to National Security
we're security and economy take
prominence over political and civil
rights
we've seen it with the Belton Road
initiative
New International Banks or other
china-led institutions
to rival the current International
System
we've seen it with China's set of global
initiatives
and by how it positions itself as a
power and peace broker for instance
through the recent Saudi Arabia and Iran
agreement
and we have seen the show of friendship
in Moscow
which says a thousand words
about this new vision
for an international order
ladies and gentlemen
with all this in mind
our response must start
by work and working to strengthening
the International System itself
we want to work with our partners on
global issues like trade Finance climate
sustainable development or health
for that we need to reinforce the
institutions and systems
in which countries can compete and
cooperate
and from which they benefit
this is why it is vitally important
that we ensure diplomatic stability
and open communication
with China
I believe it is neither viable nor in
Europe's interest to decouple from China
our relations are not black or white
and our response cannot be either
and this is why we need to focus on
de-risk not decouple
and this is part of the reason why I
will soon be visiting Beijing together
with president macron
managing this relationship
and having an open and Frank exchange
with our Chinese counterparts
is a key part of what I would call
the de-risking through diplomacy of our
relations with China
we will never be shy
in raising the deeply concerning issues
I've already set out
but I believe we must leave space for
discussion on a more ambitious
partnership
and on how we can make competition
fairer and more disciplined
and more broadly
we need to think about how we can work
together productively
the global system in the future
and on which challenges
there are some islands of opportunity
that we can build on
a climate change in nature protection
I very much welcome the leading role
China played
in securing the historic kunmin Montreal
Global biodiversity agreement
and a few weeks ago China was also an
active player
in the global deal
to protect biodiversity in international
waters
at a time of global conflict and
tensions
these are notable diplomatic
achievements with China and the European
Union worked on together
and we look forward to working together
in the same Spirit ahead of cop 28 later
this year
and this shows what can be done when
interests align
and it shows that diplomacy can still
work
whether on pandemic preparedness
nuclear non-proliferation
or Global Financial stability
Point here is
that we do not want to cut economic
societal political or scientific ties
China is a vital trading partner
accounting for nine percent of our good
Goods exports
and more than 20 percent of our Goods
Imports
while imbalances are growing
most of our trade and goods and services
remains Mutual beneficial
and unrisky
what
our relationship is unbalanced and
increasingly affected
by distortions created by China's State
capitalist system
so we need to rebalance this
relationship on the basis of
transparency predictability
and reciprocity
we have to ensure
that our trade and investment relations
promote prosperity in China and in the
European Union
the comprehensive agreement on
investment the so-called Kai
for which negotiations concluded in 2020
aimed at such rebalancing
but we have to recognize that the world
and China have changed significantly
in the last three years
and we need to reassess the Kai in light
of our wider China strategy
and we know there are some areas where
trade and investment poses risks
to our economic and National Security
particular particularly in the context
of China's explicit Fusion of its
Military and Commercial sectors
this is true for certain sensitive
Technologies dual use Goods or even
investment which comes with forced
technology or knowledge transfers
this is why after de-risking through
diplomacy
the second strand of our future China
strategy
must be economic de-risking
the starting point for this is having a
clear eyed picture on what the risks are
that means recognizing how China's
economic and security Ambitions have
shifted
but it also means taking a critical look
at our own resilience and dependencies
in particular within our industrial and
defense space
this can only be based on stress testing
our relationship
to see where the greatest threats lie
concerning our resilience
long-term prosperity and security
and this will allow us to develop our
economic de-risking strategy
across four pillars
the first one is
making our own economy and Industry more
competitive and resilient
this is particularly the case when it
comes to health digital and the
cleantech sector
if you look at the global market for Net
Zero Technologies it is set to Triple by
2030. triple
our ability ability to remain Front
Runners in this sector
will shape our economy for the decades
to come
this is why you all know it just last
week we put forward the Net Zero
industry Act
as a key part
of our green deal industrial plan
The Amos
to be able to produce at least 40
percent
of the clean tech that we need for the
green transition
such as solar
onshore and offshore wind renewable
energy in the broader sense
batteries and Storage
heat pumps and grit Technologies
but to achieve this goal
we will also need more Independence and
diversity when it comes to the key
inputs needed for our competitiveness
we know this is an era
where we rely on one single supplier
China
for 98
of our Rare Earth Supply
93 percent of our magnesium
97 of our lithium just to name a few
we are deeply mindful of what happened
with Japan's Imports of rare earth from
China a decade ago
when foreign foreign policy tensions
between the two in the East China Sea
became became acute
our demand for these materials will
Skyrocket
as a digital and the green transition
speed up
are repowering our electric batteries
that are powering our electric vehicles
are forecasted to drive up demand for
lithium
by 17 times by 2050.
this is why we have put forward the
critical raw materials Act
to help diversify
and secure our supply
and we need to think about this right
across our single Market
to strengthen our resilience
on cybern maritime
space and digital
defense and innovation
the second part of this de-risking
strategy
is better using our existing toolbox of
trade instruments
over the last past years
we've put in place measures
to address security concerns whether on
5G
the foreign direct investment
or export controls
we have given ourselves the tools
to counter-economic distortions notably
through the foreign subsidies regulation
as well as the new instrument to deter
economic coercion
we now need the unity at EU level
for Boulder and faster use of those
instruments when they are required
and a more assertive approach to
enforcement
my third point
China's changing policies may require us
to develop new defensive tools for some
critical sectors
European Union needs to Define its
future relationship with China and other
countries
insensitive high-tech areas
such as microelectronics
Quantum computing
robotics
artificial intelligence
biotech
you name it
with dual use purposes cannot be
excluded
or human rights might be implicated
there will need to be a clear line
on whether Investments or exports are in
our own security interest
we need to ensure that our companies
Capital expertise and knowledge are not
used
to enhance the military and intelligence
capabilities of those who are also
systemic rivals
so we have to look at where there are
gaps in our toolbox
which allow the leakage of emerging and
sensitive Technologies through
Investments
in other countries
and this is why
we're currently reflecting on if and how
Europe should develop a targeted
instrument
on outbound investment
is what relate to a small number of
sensitive Technologies where investment
can lead to the development of military
capabilities that pose risks to National
Security
the commission will present some initial
ideas
as part of our New Economic Security
strategy
later this year
this will map out where we need to
strengthen our Economic Security
and how to better use our trade and tech
security tools
the fourth part of our economic
de-risking strategy is alignment with
other partners
on issues that concern our Economic
Security
we have much in common with our partners
around the world
especially true to our G7 and G20
partners
and those in the region and Beyond who
are often more integrated with China
at more advanced in their thinking on
de-risking
as part of this we will focus on free
trade agreements where we do not yet
have them
such as with New Zealand Australia India
our asean and Microsoft partners
on modernizing agreements where we have
them such as Mexico and Chile
and on better using the others that
already exist
we will enhance cooperation on sectors
such as digital and clean tech
through the trade and Technology Council
with India
or the EU Japan green Alliance
and we will invest in infrastructure in
the region and Beyond through the global
gateway strategy
we are offering developing countries a
genuine choice when it comes to
infrastructure investment and finance
and all of this will help strengthen our
supply chain resilience
and diversify our trade
which must be a central element of our
economic de-risking strategy
ladies and gentlemen
we have in front of us
a task to refocus on the most important
issues
and it is a reflection
of the need to adjust our strategy
in line with the way the Chinese
Communist Party seems to be changing
but if we are to manage this
relationship
to prepare for the future
we must do it together
at this defining Moment In global
affairs
we need the collective will
to respond together
a strong European China policy relies on
strong coordination between member
states and EU institutions
and a willingness to avoid the divide
and conquer tactics
that we know we may face
but I also want to say
that nothing
is inevitable
in geopolitics
China's fascinating
and a complex mix of History progress
and challenges
and it will Define this century
but our story
about how we relate to China
is not yet fully written
and it need not be a defensive one
we must collectively show
that our democratic system
our values and our open economy
can deliver on prosperity and security
for people
and at the same time
we must always be ready
to talk and work with those
who see the world differently
which brings me back to where I started
and MAX kunchdam's Line about
working to gradually change minds and
action
is what you do every single day in your
work
and this is what Europe will always
believe in
Long Live Europe and many thanks for
your attention
thank you
[Music]